[Musique]
croire en soi c'est contagieux
nous sommes les pièces d'un fast puzzle
nous luttons au nom du droit y est je
m'appelle ellis people je suis votre
psychiatre je suis spécialisé dans le
traitement des patients qui se
considèrent comme des êtres surnaturels
jeudi en rien le fury si david dunn vous
croyez être doté d'une force
exceptionnelle mais il ya des hommes qui
sont aussi forts que vous kevin wendake
rome vous croyez que de 12 m dames
cohabitent dans votre corps
appelez-moi normal elijah price
vous avez accueilli hors norme vous
pensez être surhumain
et si je vous disais que vous vous
trompez en réalité
il nous abreuve de mensonges
vous avez été envoyés ici pour être
l'ange mangeurs êtes-vous résolu à
accomplir notre vengeance
ces individus ont perdu le sens des
réalités
beaucoup de gens vont souffrir ne faites
pas ça vous pouvez prouver au monde que
nous existons
fous rires
[Musique]
là vous seriez représenté avec des yeux
écarquillés et des points
d'interrogation au dessus de la tête